UP THE ONGOING IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
IMPEACHMENT, IMPEACHMENT,
IMPEACHMENT.
NOTHING ELSE MATTERS.
YELLED OUT IMPEACHMENT INTO YOUR
THROAT BLEEDS.
THAT'S AN ORDER.
WITH THAT, HE SLITHERED OFF BACK
TO HIS LAYER, DEEP IN THE SAND
AND CENTER OF THE ACE CAVES.
OF COURSE, THE MINIONS OBEYED.
THEY WERE AFRAID NOT TO OBEY.
BUT WE HAPPEN TO DISAGREE WITH
JEFF ZUCKER.
IF YOU ARE A COMMITTED PARTISAN
AS HE HAS, IMPEACHMENT OFTEN
LOOKS LIKE THE MOST IMPORTANT
STORY THERE IS BUT IF YOU'RE
NOT, SOMETIMES IT SEEMS LIKE
ABOUT THE FIFTH OR SIXTH MONTH
IN SPORT AND STORY PLAYING OUT
IN AMERICA RIGHT NOW.
THERE'S AN AWFUL LOT ELSE GOING
ON.
THAT'S ALL WE'VE BEEN COVERING
THE STORY ON THE SHOW WHICH IS
TO SAY NOT VERY CLOSELY BUT
TONIGHT IS NEWS TO REPORT SO WE
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO ASSESS
WHAT EXACTLY IS HAPPENING WITH
IMPEACHMENT.
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI HAS
ANNOUNCED THAT LATER THIS WEEK,
THE HOUSE WILL HOLD A FORMAL
VOTE ON PROCEDURES THAT COULD
LEAD TO A FORMAL IMPEACHMENT OF
THE PRESIDENT AT SOME POINT.
WHAT EXACTLY DOES THAT MEAN?
WHY IS IT HAPPENING?
WHAT WILL RESULT FROM IT?
WELL, ALL OF THAT UNFORTUNATELY
IS STILL OPAQUE TONIGHT.
WE ARE NOT CLEAR WHAT HIGH CRIME
THE PRESIDENT SUPPOSEDLY
COMMITTED.
THERE ARE SOME AS A CREWMAN ON
THAT QUESTION ACTUALLY EVEN ON
THE LEFT.
SO TO SOLVE THE RIDDLE, WE ARE
TAKING IN TONIGHT, AS WE OFTEN
DO YOU WIN CLAUDIA TO McCARTY,
TO THE PART OF YALE LAW SCHOOL,
THE ORACLE OF NEW YORK.
THE SINGLE MOST FAMOUS BACHELOR
DEACON IN THE UNITED STATES
SENATE, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AND
GENTLEMEN, MR. COREY A BOOKER
WHO READS TO US TONIGHT FROM HIS
PROSE TITLED, POLITICS BE.
IT DIMMED THE LIGHTS.
BE STILL TO LISTEN TO CORY.
>> I HAVE A JOB TO DO WHICH IS
TO HOLD THE EXECUTIVE
ACCOUNTABLE.
POLITICS BE.
THIS IS OUR COUNTRY.
THIS IS OUR CONSTITUTION.
POLITICS BE RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS A SAD DAY, A SAD CHAPTER
IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
POLITICS BE.
IT'S TIME TO DO WHAT IS RIGHT.
AND POLITICS BE, I JUST WANT TO
GET THE TRUTH.
I WANT TO DO MY JOBS.
I SWORE AN OATH TO UPHOLD THE
CONSTITUTION BUT I NEED TO DO
THAT.
POLITICS BE DAMNED.
>> Tucker: A HABIT.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT POLITICS,
CORY BOOKER SAYS, IT'S ABOUT
DOING WHAT IS RIGHT, AS IT
ALWAYS IS IN WASHINGTON.
AND IF YOU HAVE ANY DOUBT ABOUT
THAT, HE WILL SAY IT AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND AGAIN UNTIL YOU ARE
TOO EXHAUSTED OR HYPNOTIZED TO
PROTEST WHICH OUGHT TO BE A
TIP-OFF THAT IN FACT THE
OPPOSITE IS TRUE.
ACTUALLY, THIS IS ENTIRELY ABOUT
POLITICS.
THERE IS NO REAL CRIME BEHIND
THE IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS.
INSTEAD, THE PRESIDENT'S CHIEF
OFFENSE APPEARS TO BE
DISAGREEING WITH POLICIES SET BY
THE BUREAUCRATIC STATE FROM
WASHINGTON.
HOW DO WE KNOW THAT?
BECAUSE HE ESSENTIALLY ADMITTED
IT READ OVER THE LAST TWO WEEKS,
AND THE HOUSE HAS HEARD
TESTIMONY FROM A DIPLOMAT CALLED
BILL TAYLOR AND ALEXANDER
VIN'S BEEN PAID AT THEIR
STATEMENTS, WE ARE TOLD, WILL
SINK PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT MAY BE.
WHAT ARE THEY SET?
THEY ARE INTENSE RUSSIA HAWKS,
BOTH HAVE TESTIFIED THAT THEY
WANT HEAVY AMERICAN AID TO
UKRAINE BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
WEAKEN RUSSIA.
BOTH OF THEM DECIDES THEY DON'T
WANT ANY IN FAITH IN THE U.S.
ABOUT THESE POLICIES.
THEY SAID THAT OUT LOUD.
IN HIS REMARKS, HE SAID HE
OPPOSED PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PHONE
CALL WITH THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE FOR THIS REASON.
QUOTE, "I REALIZE THAT IF
UKRAINE PURSUED AN INVESTIGATION
INTO THE BIDENS IN BURISMA, IT
WOULD LIKELY BE INTERPRETED AS A
PARTISAN PLAY WHICH WOULD
UNDOUBTEDLY RESULT IN UKRAINE
LOSING THE BIPARTISAN PORTS.
IT IS THUS FAR MAINTAINED.
IT" THE IMPLICATION IS, THAT
WOULD BE UNEXCEPT BOTH SAID
SOMETHING ALMOST IDENTICAL TO
THAT.
"TO RESTORE UKRAINE'S
INDEPENDENCE, AND RUSSIA MUST
LEAVE UKRAINE.
THIS HAS BEEN AND SHOULD
CONTINUE TO BE A BIPARTISAN U.S.
FOREIGN POLICY GOAL."
IN OTHER WORDS, WASHINGTON MAY
HAVE TWO PARTIES BUT ONLY ONE
POSITION ON UKRAINE IS ALLOWED
HERE.
TRUMP DOESN'T HAVE IT.
HIS PHONE CALL WAS UNACCEPTABLE
BECAUSE IT MIGHT PREVENT AMERICA
FROM AUTOMATICALLY UNTHINKINGLY
SPENDING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OVER MANY YEARS TO PROP UP A
COUNTRY THAT MOST AMERICANS
COULD NOT FIND ON THE GLOBE AT
GUNPOINT.
THERE'S JUST ONE PROBLEM WITH
THIS ARRANGEMENT.
VOTERS DISAGREE.
WE KNOW THIS BECAUSE WHEN HE RAN
THREE YEARS AGO, PRESIDENT TRUMP
DIDN'T HIDE HOW HE FELT ABOUT
U.S. FOREIGN POLICY.
HE TOLD VOTERS THAT AMERICA WAS
INVOLVED IN TOO MANY POINTLESS
WARS BUT HE CRITICIZED THAT THEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA FOR HAVING
BETTER RELATIONS WITH RUSSIA.
A TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, HE
PROMISED, WOULD PURSUE BETTER
RELATIONS WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THAT MAY SOUND SHOCKING BUT IN
FACT IT WAS NOT AN UNPRECEDENTED
IDEA.
OBAMA RAN ON SOMETHING CLOSE TO
THIS IN 2012 AND THE PUBLIC
SUPPORTED IT THEN TOO.
HE WON THAT IT NOW THAT SAME
IDEA ISN'T SIMPLY UNPOPULAR IN
WASHINGTON, A RULING CLASS
CONSIDERS IT ILLEGAL.
FORMER CIA HAD JOHN BRENNAN PUT
IT THIS WAY ON TWITTER.
"AS IN PREVIOUS TIMES OF
NATIONAL PERIL, WE RELY ON
MILITARY, DIPLOMATS,
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS,
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS, AND
OTHER COURAGEOUS PATRIOTS TO
PROTECT OUR LIBERTIES, FREEDOM,
AND DEMOCRACY.
MAY THEY STAY RESOLUTE AND
STRONG DESPITE CORRUPT POLITICAL
HEADWINDS THEY FACE" GOT THAT?
UNELECTED BUREAUCRATS UPHOLD,
WAIT FOR, DEMOCRACY.
ELECTED OFFICIALS SUBVERT
DEMOCRACY.
IN JOHN BRENNAN'S WORLD, THE
MOST PRESSING AND IMMINENT
THREAT TO THIS REPUBLIC IT IS
VOTERS.
CHARLIE HURT'S OPINION EDITOR
FROM "THE WASHINGTON TIMES" AND
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK STILL
WINNING.
IT WHY AMERICA WENT ALL IN ON
DONALD TRUMP AND MUST DO IT
AGAIN.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
WHAT YOU THINK IMPEACHMENT IS
ACTUALLY ABOUT?
>> I THINK WITHOUT A DOUBT, IT